new details are emerging about an
American Navy veteran being held captive
in Iran the family of Michael White
revealed this week he's been in
captivity since last summer his mother
says she has no idea about possible
charges Face the Nation moderator and
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan is that the State
Department's more on this story Margaret
good morning good morning well Michael
White is the fourth American to be held
by Iran and while CBS News learned that
Iran floated the idea of a prisoner
exchange
last year State Department officials
will not say whether the Trump
administration is now willing to
negotiate contact between the two
countries was cut off after President
Trump exited the nuclear deal after
American Michael White didn't board his
flight back from Iran last July the
forty six year olds mother filed a
missing-persons report about five months
later the State Department informed her
that he's being held in Iranian prison
I'm very worried about his health
she told CBS News he just got over
cancer and I'm worried about his
condition it's very scary to me
according to his family the California
native had traveled to Iran three times
to visit a woman believed to be his
girlfriend Iran's leaders so chaos death
and destruction president Trump's
hardline stance exiting the nuclear deal
and sanctioning Iran has not stopped it
from continuing to detain three other
Americans including siamak no mozzie
seen here in this propaganda video and
his 82 year old father iran's Foreign
Minister told CBS News last April that
Iran is open to a prisoner swap it's a
possibility certainly from a
humanitarian perspective but president
Trump has vowed not to broker the type
of deal that President Obama greenlit in
2016 which unfroze Iranian assets and
freed four Americans including
Washington Post journalist Jason rezaian
I didn't do what Obama did give him 1.8
billion dollars in cash to get back for
hostages in order to get anything done
the two countries have to speak to each
other
Christine Levinson's husband former FBI
agent Bob Levinson has been missing in
Iran since 2007 his whereabouts are
unknown they're being kept from their
families and they need to come home
now sources tell CBS News that Iran is
holding the prisoners to extract
concessions such as those received in
the Obama era trade and John senior
administration official tells me that at
least one offer made to talk was turned
down and that leaves the fate of all of
these Americans unclear all right
Margaret Brennan thank you very much
Margaret